today I want to talk about what I like
what I'm gonna call a snowball effect of
language money and the reason I'm
talking about it today is that I
suddenly realized that you know I was
leafing through this new history book
that I'm reading about the history of
Czechoslovakia you know the Czech lands
so to speak and you know I'm just able
to read more and more of it and I
grabbed my old copy of you know the OCD
dobrica voice Rica where you know when I
first started on this working on link
and having to look up every second word
and not understanding much of what I
listened to it was a hard going but now
I can I can pretty well like I have a
book because I'm still working on it you
know with the help of a blink but I can
open it up just about anywhere and I can
actually make sense of most of most of
what I read in the book here right then
it's a nice big you know hardcover book
when I listen to any number of the
podcasts from Czech radio and there are
so many from chest eros class and I can
understand most of what there's talking
about now sorry argument tea or whatever
it is argument ionizer Gnostic I don't
know I can understand most of it and and
so it made me realize that you know the
more you understand the more you can
learn so that you know whereas listening
to some of this before would have just
been background noise I now have enough
of it I have enough words and I'm used
to it
enough that I'm actually able to just
put it on to the background and actually
learn from it so that it's this whole
sense that I've described this before of
the sort of you know the rich get richer
and the poor get poorer the more words
you have the more you can learn the more
you can infer just as as in our own
native language the more vocabulary we
have the more difficult material we can
learn the more we can improve our
language skills through input activities
and and I make this point because you
know I I must admit that I don't do a
lot of speaking in Czech I occasionally
talk to some of our tutors particularly
with the yarda and I might do it once or
twice a week you know I might go a
couple of weeks without doing it I am
gonna try to get back to doing it but
when I speak of course I have a very
limited vocabulary but when I am
listening and reading and working
through content that link I'm constantly
increasing my vocabulary and so the
snowball is moving I met today with a
friend of mine who is an Italian
Canadian who speaks very limited Italian
and for 13 years he's been going to the
same town in Italy in Calabria and he
spent a month there and he says he wants
to learn Italian and he's learned enough
that he can say a few things to his he
has a good friend there in Italian and
he speaks to his parents and he can kind
of say very very simple things but the
biggest problem he says is that when
they start speaking he doesn't
understand what they're saying he can't
understand the radio he can't understand
any of the background he can't pick up
the language from all the stuff that's
easily accessible so he's his snowball
is very small and I was trying to
persuade him that you know don't worry
about what you can say at this point
worry about starting to make that
snowball bigger worry about building up
your comprehension building up your
vocabulary and and then once that starts
to happen and you can learn from the
newspaper you can learn from books you
can learn from listening to the radio so
many more things are going to help you
so you know and I think too for example
here in Canada the government recently
announced that they're going to insist
on you know English language
requirements for immigrants and of
course typically there was some guy who
wrote in the local Chinese paper I read
you know this is anti Asian it's and it
comes drags in the head tax and
everything else he could think of it's
not it just makes sense because because
you need English to operate here but the
government is only asking for level four
on the Canadian benchmarks which is
really quite low so I'm gonna try to
meet with some immigrants who are
struggling with English and try to
persuade them that they've got to build
up their comp
engine skills they've got to get the
snowball going I mean eventually we have
to speak eventually we had to speak and
when we speak we started but the bigger
your snowball the more words you have
the more you understand the more
comfortable you are with different
aspects of the language the better
you're going to do when you start to
speak so rather than trying to sort of I
might say build a very small perfect
little snowman out of the little bit
that you have I believe and I mean we
all go out these things differently but
for me I far rather just let my snowball
run down that hill get as big as it can
possibly be and then when circumstances
permit when I have the opportunity or
the need then I start into more
aggressive speaking and yeah I have to
speak a lot in order to be able to speak
well but if I have a big snowball behind
me it's gonna carry me forward so there
you have it the snowball of language
learning